لم يسبق لي أن رأيت خريجًا يبلغ من العمر تسع سنوات
ولكن هذا هو بالضبط ما فعله ديفيد بالاجون البالغ من العمر تسع سنوات عندما
تخرج من
مدرسة سايبر تشارتر في هاريسبرج، نحن
فخورون فقط بأننا قادرون على تخصيص
تعليماته بشكل فردي.
لم يعرقلوني، لقد دافعوا
عني أيضًا قائلين إنه يستطيع فعل هذا، يمكنه فعل ذلك،
أخذ ديفيد دروسًا عن بعد من
منزله في مقاطعة باكس، إنه يحب
العلوم وبرمجة الكمبيوتر، أريد
أن أصبح عالمًا فيزياء فلكية وأردت
دراسة
الثقوب السوداء
والمستعر الأعظم لديفيد  الآباء لديهم
درجات علمية متقدمة ولكن تربية ابن صغير يتمتع
بمواهب فكرية غير عادية يمثل
تحديًا، كان علي أن أخرج من
الصندوق وألعب فاتورة المعارك عندما
لا يكون من المفترض أن ترمي الكرات في
المنزل كما لو كان يبلغ من العمر تسع سنوات
ولديه  عقل يتمتع بالقدرة على
الفهم واستيعاب الكثير من
المفاهيم التي تتجاوز سنوات عمره وأحيانًا
تتجاوز فهمي،
أحد أعضاء منسا ديفيد ينسب الفضل إلى عدد
من المعلمين المفضلين السيد الذي علمهم
شيئًا أو اثنين في السنوات القليلة التي
استغرقها الأمر  من أجل اجتياز الصف الثاني عشر،
كان ديفيد طفلاً ملهمًا بالتأكيد،
حيث قام بتغيير طريقة تفكيرك في
التدريس بعد إكمال فصل دراسي في
كلية مجتمع مقاطعة باكس،
وتبحث العائلة الآن عن الكليات
والجامعات في جميع أنحاء البلاد لمحاولة
العثور على واحدة مناسبة  مناسب تمامًا،
هل سأرسل طفلي البالغ من العمر
تسع سنوات إلى جامعة هارفارد بينما
أعيش في السلطة الفلسطينية، لا يوجد سؤال صعب آخر في
هذه الرحلة الفريدة ولكن حتى الآن
توصل ديفيد ومن حوله إلى
الإجابات الصحيحة